damn for us a blessing I'm gonna pay for
this what are you doing artist legal
cannabis laying around for me to take
well last year if you recall we paired
the most expensive cannabis with the
most expensive papers that was fun but
today we need to take it up a notch
a weed right here has about 20 percent
25 percent THC and so we took the THC
out of this and we made it in canvas and
that's straight by th straight THC we
call taking a little bit of this we call
it taking a dab of hash oil
Oh tell me man this makes it feel
like your heart is a buttocks blow I
actually have a table here filled with
probably a half a million dollars worth
of glass with those even touch this
that's a scorpion evil bit ha evil
that's yeah yeah and that's some real
white people shoes white it
don't get too hot yet we're not I'm good
okay hang on Adam he's gonna break down
why this is the most expensive sesh you
will ever have feeling I'm feeling good
they ready
you took a $50,000 hit out of the banjo
right here you like it let's you didn't
even know that the reason why I'm some
of these pieces are the way they are is
just like any brand like fashion or
alcohol I could get like a regular
cotton t-shirt from any store for like
fireworks or I don't like the Versace
store you get a concert and spend $500
daddy you got it it's about that dab
light dab in your debit or you know
family
listen film taste something I'm tell you
right now I mean this is this a
what is this oh this is a microphone
blood it's a customer with your name on
it all gold
I know you were talking about that gold
paper so I took the gold paper and at my
boy Weaver's and say we need to make a
go blunt for my boy 2 Chainz I'm gonna
do the rest of the interview
[Music]
oh yes why tell the people until the
American people wise okay well banjo is
a very reputable artist and he's a
respected in the industry it's very
innovative those who did this
banjo saw the bench I'll keep doing your
thing man
two chains Street exec studios that you
know I will make sure that you get
address banjo all right what else you
got bro
is that a steep up mr. marshmallow
Buster's yeah so you just use the straw
net and thousand dollar pipe it's the
original honey berry so these start out
like 25k this is 25,000 yeah I like the
My Little Pony me personally I mean cuz
I know you like the gold papers and I
like the blunts are there little collab
like a lot of these artists do I've got
a $3,000 front feet the shotgun a
pump-action stocking with that tip
custom little tip how much time do you
have
I like to get high man its THC whoa with
Harry oh gee terpenes it's so loud so
that's about close to 25 dollars but is
little time Wright brothers 25 how
you supposed to smoke this
you damn it put me in the game coach put
a mannequin at you I got to set up I get
you a nail put some water in there and
we got it we'll get the dance ready
let's do it
so should I do not heat up the surface
you get the right temperature go in
there's 63 compounds
in the cannabis plant and we only want
one main ingredient which is the THC and
that's what we're doing right here your
bronchial sacs to chain so that was
probably the equivalent of smoking I was
like a mountain yeah that was like at
least two of these in one hit every turn
call my doctor she comes to I feel like
dr. Dean can parallel park a train
that's how cool dr. D means she likes
getting the boy high you see always come
this interesting products faith oh
get your geek and really make you
develop a wild ass at the time or do we
know how to up some food so you
know what it is dr. Tina that's my
sweetheart
that's my tart that's what it is true